-Thanks to newly developed
technology, we here at
"Late Night" have the ability
to record the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that like everyone's
inner voice, Donald Trump's
is filled with paralyzing fear
and self-doubt.
So here is the tiny voice
in the back of
Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Something that we think
is very valuable.
-[ As Trump ] Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice in the back
of your head, and I'm here
to remind you that
you hate being President,
and you would give anything
right now to trade places
with this little kid in
his dad's lap to your right.
You have to pretend to listen
to this lady, and nod.
Meanwhile, he gets to play
with his dad's big old hand.
Looks like so much fun,
rocking back and forth.
And you have to sit still.
He probably gets to throw
a temper tantrum, too.
When he throws a temper tantrum
it's cute, but when you do it,
everyone on CNN says,
"Oh, he's a baby."
Oh no, he's going to yawn.
Oh, you want to yawn
so bad, and oh,
that lucky son of
a bitch is taking a nap.
-Intellectual property rights.
-[ As Trump ] Hey, Donald.
It's me, the tiny voice
in the back
in your head and wow,
look at your Secretary
of Commerce, Wilbur Ross.
You thought you would get
to work with the coolest people
if you were President,
but look who is in your cabinet:
A very small man hovering around
the age of 112 who does not know
how to lower a microphone.
It looks like his eyeballs
are giving a speech.
And if his eyeballs were giving
a speech I bet they'd say,
"Somebody get us out
of this old-ass head."
No one is watching
this right now saying,
"Oh, I wish I could switch
places with Donald Trump,
and hang out with Wilbur Ross,
and Mike Pence."
Look what you've done
with your life.
You used to roll
with porn stars, and now
you're with Boresville
and Snoresville.
Sad.
♪♪♪♪